when I get home at night I take all the
coins in my pocket and I throw them into
a box then every year I give them to a
local charity last time the total came
to nearly 500 pounds and obviously the
charity is keen to take them because
there's lots of silver in the box you
know two pounds one pound 50 bitcoins
what's interesting is that even some
charities now aren't very keen to take 2
P and 1p coins because they know what we
all know they're virtually worthless now
Bank of England analysts say getting rid
of these coins just as it got rid of the
half penny in 1984 wouldn't impact
prices the Chancellor Philip Hammond is
under pressure to finally scrap coppers
in this November budget what we all know
is that if he does all sorts of
commentators you know people like Nick
and Cowell and politicians will scream
that it we're fuel inflation but the
truth is these coins have no real value
anyway so come on Mr Hammond take the
plunge you're used to being unpopular
anyway and I think a few things they are
of value they're of one pence value and
of two pence value I didn't actually
realize though you can't use pennies as
legal tender for an amount beyond 20
pence in a single thing so if you want
to pay off you know your 200 pound debt
with one penny as you can't I didn't
realize that so that's the first thing
that they actually they do have a value
of 1 & 2 P the second thing is charities
they do and when you look at the China
the charity Finance Commission they
actually say that charities are making
millions of pounds a year in donations
because of one and two PS for example no
that's not according to me there's a
charity the charity Finance Group
estimates millions of pounds worth of 1
+ 2 pence coins are donated to charities
every single year not my stats this is
their stats so that's the first thing
that actually you don't need so if we
are all choking our ones and twos and I
would pick off a penny on the street by
the way I mainly for superstitious
reason I agree
secondly when I go to likely Fox or
wherever I like my two pence slot
machines I'm too tight to play on the 10
pence one now often what would I need
rolls
slot machines with my family for dour of
course they are kids to braid or
Scarborough or keep okay
they're brilliant but did you know get
60% of 1p and 2p coins only used once
60% of you can I just say you go first I
want to come to your house to your box
because of your chair and one and two
pine cones and I want to be there to
collect it but anyway chances are pretty
slim I work my finger there I've got a
quote from the charity finance but this
sum is that millions of pounds worth of
one or two bitcoins are donated to
charities every year and they're saying
this is particularly true of smaller
charities who are more likely to depend
on cash donations and you know one you
might say 1 2 P is useless and it might
be to you you're a rich man but to
someone who's on a minimum wage an
average wage Penny's matter and you know
you laughed at the idea of inflation
supermarkets and shops will round it up
to five PV will pay places so shops like
little children 49p for a fight but
we'll put the prices up and that matters
to people on a budget when they got rid
of a half piece and everybody said that
that's not what happened
- but 2p is different and 1p today won't
be today if you take win the 1 these are
the new people those of us old enough
remember there's decimalisation survival
of any the new penny
in 1971 is worth 13 P today so actually
you inflation brought in in 71 when a
pound him it was 5 pins and a white loaf
tempered but but I you know they did a
report on this and and one and only one
in five want to get rid of these and
that means that 80% of people don't want
to give her don't you think matter to
them let me just say I think guys hate
coins because it messes up the whole
industry and I read that a percent of
guys throw them away I don't think men
would ever say when I pick them up in
the morning yes of course
I've said this before delighted the
assignor I celebrate your success good
luck to you've worked damn hard you
deserve it all but on this one you're
out of touch you're totally out of touch
what is the store that opened this week
which is absolutely playing jacks Tesco
see the incarnation is really going
after the net owes the Aldi the Lidl and
all of us that is where real people are
if the hold on one second support if
they can pay 49p for a loaf of bread
instead of 50 P they are going to go and
I don't mean this nasty and it's good -
it's all right for you great the money
goes to charity the real world out there
there are nurses there are teachers
their firefighters watching this program
say there's me a bloody break I need
that tup and self a pint of baked beans
and then I get 5p off of course that
won't go that way 60% of these coins
aren't used and however we have 500
million and are produced every year
here's no time for my exciting statistic
can we have thought the Royal Mint
produces one and 2p coins 500 million
are produced well in 2015 2016 and if
they're only used what once or twice
you're right it's there shrapnel I mean
when I go and get a cup of coffee and
there's a a charity box I always take my
put coin and I cake all the coppers er
and I stick them in that's good and now
you think right I think it's keeping
charities afloat and the very low pay
back in Kerala you're doing that my one
of my mates dance used to come a many
Dempsey's pockets and that's just
maddening me used to chuck his money and
go scramble and all of us kids go to the
goodie shop and it turned out anyway was
convicted with being a drug dealer
should we listen to war and other people
on the street think about this any job
what you what you actually see pardon
prepar maybe
if you saw one on the street would you
stop to pick it up I've been hot
appointments I just fare change the
couple all the time a one pound coin
they should buy something with them the
one or two fetish coins are worthless we
shall give it in yet too messy about we
should stick to the main hole absolutely
too much English English keep the
original stuff that's the originals that
keep them that's why ya see a penny pick
it up the other side of it I was in
Vietnam a couple of weeks ago and I was
walking around with millions and
millions of dong to pay for bits and
pieces and you feel like you've got all
this money and you've got like words and
words and words of thousands of donors
and they're like they're not worth a lot
could never have enough done really if
we did get rid of them I think it would
impoverished the language how could you
say to your children are you gonna spend
a penny a penny now by the way my
grandma used to say spend a penny and
spend tuppence
but maybe that's too much information I
was getting married in your string but
the bride would chuck out a whole bunch
of pennies from the car and all these
all of us kids but till she runs along
tarmac together greatly just full of old
but they'll be worth a few quid then
you'll never do it they'll really Greg
back the Chancellor he'll never know
because you've upset those people some
of those some of those people print you
know stop making so many and let them
just go out of circulation they did the
work that was talk so I gonna do it
earlier in the year and there was a
massive outcry against a massive outcry
was it'd be like you and Nick know what
the newspapers
my radio presenter as well before we go
there's just time for this in politics a
good sound bite can be everything you
know Beck's it means breaks it strong
and stable for the many not the few
these catchy phrases can define a leader
while hoping to join the hallows group
this week was Lib Dem leader servants
giving a speech to his party conference
in Brighton
we were told he'd be summing up hardline
big cities as experiencing an erotic
spasm then he was suggested the phrase
would be exotic spasm and then we
finally got to the big moment for the
true believers the the fundamentalists
the costs of brexit have always been
irrelevant years of economic pain
justified by the exotics present of
leaving the european union's the exotics
present express omics present the
exotics of leaving the European Union to
me then that that's not a real word I
know it's not a real Russian nervous
about it for this episode of the pledge
see you next time
[Music]
you